hello and welcome to the third debate of
intelligent squared crypto a new series
from intelligence squared in partnership
with equinix i'm anne mckelvoy from the
economist and tonight's debate is crypto
can bank the unbanked
before we begin i'm going to ask you the
audience to submit a pre-vote to get a
sense of where your opinions lie you'll
know that we do this if you've attended
previously or even if you haven't it's
pretty simple you vote for or against
the motion crypto can bank the unbanked
via the poll coming up on your screen
if you are unsure
you vote undecided
just while that is being calculated a
reminder that our last debate was crypto
versus the environment and in a twitter
poll we ran last week 45 percent of
people thought crypto was a threat to
the environment 44
thought it wasn't that's finely balanced
and 11
were undecided i would say across the
series that's a relatively low number of
undecideds so either the debate uh
swayed them or they were just people
with very firm opinions but you can
catch up with the live audience results
on the intelligence squared podcast
so tonight's debate couldn't be more
timely on monday september the 7th el
salvador became the first country to
accept bitcoin as legal tender
businesses there will be obliged where
possible to accept digital coins as
payment and citizens will be expected to
download the government's new digital
wallet app which gives away thirty
dollars in bitcoin to every citizen
bitcoin funds have of course been
jumping for joy about this they believe
the adoption of cryptocurrency in
low-income countries like el salvador
can provide banking services to two
billion people around the world
potentially who are unbanked
let's take el salvador there as an
example 70 of citizens unbanked roughly
a quarter of the working population
lives in the u.s and sends remittance
payments home to families well in future
these payments could be made by bitcoin
dramatically reducing cross-border fees
and allowing families to send
cryptocurrency straight to the mobile
phone of their loved ones but some
security experts still have doubts
banking the unbanked might sound like a
bright idea they say but it assumes that
people who lack financial services
primarily need a better and a cheaper
way to access them a 2015 world bank
report found that 59 of survey
respondents cited lack of money as the
main reason for not having a bank
account so rather than luring people
into the murky world of cryptocurrency
where volatile prices such as the recent
drop in bitcoin can make the poor poorer
should we not be looking instead at
other solutions to bank the unbanked
that is the theme of our show tonight um
i am just going to read you the results
of the first vote and i'm very much
hoping i get to see it
because i can't quite see it at the
moment but that's probably my bad
looking in the wrong place
uh actually i can i can okay
i also realize i have a
phone that needs to be dismissed but
we'll get rid of that minute crypto can
bank the unbanked for 49
against 15
undecided a whopping 36
goodness gentlemen all is to play for
our speakers i'm about to
to introduce 449 against 15 undecided is
36 there
so let's introduce our speakers and
arguing for the motion this evening is
peter mccormack journalist investor host
of the hit podcast what bitcoin did in
which he focuses on human rights
censorship and cryptocurrencies he spent
the last number of days in el salvador
and has previously met with the
president there to discuss the adoption
of bitcoin in that country well that
clearly worked out peter so peter you
are going to speak first for six minutes
um i'm reasonably strict about that and
then i will be passing over to yaya
fanuzi who is going to oppose you i'll
introduce yaya properly when we've heard
from peter but please take us away
tonight on banking the unbanked
yes uh thank you for having me here i
don't think i'm going to need six
minutes so i'll give ya plenty more time
for his side um
the the debate is uh whether
crypto can bank me on bank so just a
couple of things i'm gonna focus uh
entirely on bitcoin with my arguments
and uh that's what my podcast does i
very look at other very rarely look
other cryptocurrencies
so uh the premise of the debate is can
uh crypto i'm gonna say bitcoin bank the
young banks well it already is so
if you look at what banking services are
it's the ability to hold save money and
access financial services well
applications that have been built uh on
top of the bitcoin network are already
providing these services to people who
do not have bank accounts i've seen it
right here in el salvador i've met
people who previously would not save
money who've had access to bitcoin and
they've had the ability to save money
and grow their investment and buy new
things
i met an old chap who had his teeth done
he was now looking to buy a cow i met a
lady who accepts uh bitcoin in her shop
when it was previously cash only is now
buying a car
so
the premise of the debate has already
been proven false because bitcoin is
banking the unbanked already i'd also
just add in something else bitcoin
doesn't only bank the unbanked but it
also re-banks those who are already
banked uh people who have access to
certain financial services are gradually
moving their financial services over to
bitcoin so i would say myself i'm
personally in a transitionary phase uh
i've had bank accounts closed down now
part of my banking is provided
on the bitcoin network um and i'm
increasingly moving away from the
traditional networks this this week i've
had revolut my personal bank asking for
a considerable amount of kyc aml
information and my account was actually
locked for over a month which meant i
couldn't access certain financial
services i've had similar issues with
bing
business banking whereby lawyers tsb my
bank for 25 years uh closed down my
accounts at six weeks notice uh because
they were running government
surveillance and i refused to give them
information i did not think that was uh
required for them to have so again i've
i'm gradually in this transition from
traditional banking to neo banking to uh
bitcoin banking i expect at some point
along this timeline i will bank entirely
on the bitcoin network and won't be
using the traditional networks
especially now as we have stable coins
being created on liquid and lightning so
yes the premise of the debate is uh can
bitcoin bank the unbanked it already is
so
um the debate has already been won i'm
not really sure what we're here to talk
about
oh
very brave very brave i like that you
led with your chin on that one peter
well let's uh see what your opponent
makes of that and then of course we'll
hear from our audience and we're very
keen to get your questions on this
whether you know a lot about it or
whether you don't because one thing i
certainly found with our our last crypto
um debate or debates was that
a lot of people were coming from a high
level and a lot and other people were
simply confused but very curious and i'm
absolutely open to questions uh from
both ends of the spectrum or indeed
anyone in the middle but yaya fanuzi
you've just been issued quite a
challenge there apparently this is all
over i think it's all over well it isn't
now because yaya is a senior fellow at
the center for a new american security
he's also host of the rhythm of wisdom
podcast he researches the national
security implications of cryptocurrency
and blockchain technology spent seven
years as an economic and
counter-terrorism analyst in cia we're
briefing federal law enforcement of
white house level policy makers included
george w bush yaya banking the unbanked
is it as simple or are there other
elements that we ought to be bearing in
mind for the upbeat account that we got
from peter
thank you and thank you peter great to
be be here with you and let me before i
start give a little bit of context
because many people may not know uh my
background uh in terms of the crypto
space i actually do a lot of consulting
with crypto uh firms or for firms that
are sort of building crypto and
blockchain applications so this is not
uh this is not a a
roubini sort of debate going on here so
from small scrappy startups to large
major um uh tech firms that deal with
crypto
but to get to the debate uh very
interesting peter i think i'll take this
tack which is that you know crypto for
crypto to bank the unbanked i think it's
a pithy well-meaning phrase but it's
based on a few unchecked assumptions uh
that make it a poor framing for how to
solve the real problems of the unbanked
so i'm going to start with let's look at
those three assumptions the first
unchecked assumption is that the primary
cause of the unbanked is that banking as
a service is sort of not within the
reach whether physically or lack of
identification due to anti-money
laundering
kyc know your customer requirements um
but let's look at let's sort of drill
down right i actually looked at this
issue with the philippines uh not too
long ago because the philippines has a
huge unbanked population and there was a
study done
by the government which actually looked
at the end bank there's about 50 some
million people adults without bank
accounts in the philippines huge
remittances uh remittance uh market and
out of those uh 52 million adults 60
percent cited not having enough money as
the reason why they did not have a bank
account that was the chunk of uh uh uh
that was the reason for right for the
biggest chunk of people and this then
followed by perceived lack of need about
21 and then the absence of documentation
was about 18
so what does that mean it means that
the key reason
that folks are unbanked is simply not
having enough money the primary problem
is an income problem so you have an
economic productivity problem or maybe
you frame it as an economic opportunity
problem but it's not a technological one
and so when you're also talking about
participating in financial services
whether it is you know a rural farmer
whether it is peter who's you know is
you know know in the western world but
then wants to kind of get out of the
the traditional system
you're talking about having the surplus
to participate in these financial
services you're not talking about being
at a subsistence level because if you're
at a subsistence level it's very
difficult to find financial services so
that's really the issue the problem is
that when it comes to generating income
or more wealth there's no singular app
for that so it's really a tougher
problem the second unchecked assumption
is that you know we're sort of talking
about this idea of decentralized more
sort of pseudo-anonymous
finance right the second assumption is
that this decentralized finance can
scale to offer an alternative and maybe
even better financial sector for the
unbanked or underbanked and here's the
problem because i deal with this a lot
because i deal a lot with the regulatory
issues in the crypto space
the thing is that the pseudonymity the
fact that you know crypto is so open and
anyone can download a wallet anyone can
transact but the pseudonymity aspect
actually means that it can only go so
far and let me tell you what i mean
um unless i hate to sort of be the buzz
kill here maybe but
until you sort of build that know your
customer layer and that anti-money
laundering layer into a financial
service
you can't scale those enterprises at
least you can at least just you can't
sustain it and what we're in right now
is similar to the ico phase the initial
coin offering phase in crypto where you
know what four or five years ago lots of
people were raising money because anyone
could create a token and now hey we're
at a position where um
now we're at a position where regulators
have caught up so that's where we are
and the other thing is banking is
evolving so banking is not static
banking is actually involving of all
evolving to include crypto assets and
banking could include crypto assets but
still there's the aml kyc requirement
and then the third assumption that i'll
end on is this there's this undercurrent
here that investing in crypto is a
sufficient and comprehensive wealth
strategy now i'm not here to down
investing in crypto or anything like
that but i'll end with the story do i
have like a few seconds or did i go did
i okay yeah so here's the story 2018 i
was out in miami i had been invited to
speak to a group of bankers on in miami
beach at the beach this is really
interesting and i was talking about a
little illicit risk in crypto i did my
little spiel and
the audience of bankers so i always ask
who in the audience owns crypto none of
the bankers raised their hand right as
you would expect
but guess who raised their hand
the wait staff the servers the audio
visual people right they all said yeah i
own crypto and you know i raised my hand
as well
afterwards when i was done with my
presentation one of the av guys came up
to me and he said he was like he wanted
to get my advice i guess he saw me as an
expert i wasn't you know an expert
person i was just talking about this the
space that i follow and he said hey what
do you think about this one token and it
was a token i had never heard of i won't
say the name right i don't want to you
know make people angry
and so it was a token i had never heard
of but he was like he was so caught up
in like this one token do i think this
is it this was 2018 when the icos were
really big
i took a look recently i looked at that
token and that token had ico'ed at about
25 cents that token is now worth about
point zero point it's about one cent
it's lost ninety four percent ninety
eight percent of its value since it
ico'd this is not to down crypto in
general or bitcoin but it's to say that
there's this environment where people
are looking for this quick solution and
the low barrier to entry actually makes
it easy for people to get scammed for
people to really be involved in a very
risky environment and who goes for that
the folks who are promised the idea of
crypto as a quick way to wealth
generation wealth generation is a lot
more complicated we have to be careful
with people's money so i'm going to wrap
up there's so many other things that i'd
love to say but those three assumptions
i think we need to check uh because if
we really want to solve the problem it's
not a technological one alone
you just made it i was just about to i
was just going to come on with a big a
big big hook but you you packed a lot in
there yeah yes so thank you very much um
we're already getting a load of
questions which i'm thrilled about if
you'd like to make my life easier and i
know that's really why you came along
tonight guys and uh and uh all guys guys
have all sexism joined us it you could
put things in q a the chat gets very
full and the chat is a bit hard to
distinguish uh someone just telling
telling us off for something or telling
me that you know i've hiccuped uh but
the q a is probably the best place to
put your questions you might get favored
a bit of your question if you're in the
q a um i feel peter that you might have
a have some thoughts in return uh on
those factors and i'd just like to probe
a bit on
scale i understood your point that what
we were arguing about if you were
already involved in a world where you
felt that this was
working you could see it working you
think it was working for you and and for
a country you spend a lot of time in but
the scalability issue did arrive there
and that's before we got to perhaps some
of the other trip wires would you give
us a couple of responses
yeah so um some good points there and
i'd like to respond i've tried to keep
as best votes as possible firstly i'll
i'll explain where i agree with eia um i
mean icos were dumb and stupid uh i i
don't even compare them to bitcoin to me
they the only similarity they have is
some people learn to use a bitcoin uh to
use a blockchain to convince people of
ideas and scan them into investing in
things
um
that's just a fact of life whether it's
the internet or
people on the street people have there's
a history of people scamming uh others
to try and make money from them whether
it's ponzi schemes or
mln schemes but they really do have very
little comparison to bitcoin for me and
that's why my show is called what
bitcoin did i only focus on bitcoin and
when people ask me to cover uh any other
alternative currencies or [ __ ] coins i
just ignore them because they have
almost zero relevance to my life and
that's why i've said i'm going to focus
on bitcoin uh and if we're talking about
can crypto banking on banks i'm going to
talk about whether bitcoin can bank down
banked um i think icos are absolutely
nonsense and they have scam people i
think it's very sad
um so let's talk about the uh
eia's um
well actually you know i'd like to start
with just a little bit on yay's
background there's a there's a c-i-n-i-a
analyst and essentially a spook i'm not
surprised he's taken the counter
position to this but the cia has a
history of many controversies trying to
interfere in things and and causing many
problems around the world causing
oppression financial oppression and uh
uh
numerous human rights violations so
i'm not surprised he takes the
anti-position because uh he he has the
belief that a centralized authority can
make the world a better place but i
think there's many people who argue that
cia has made the world a more dangerous
and and bad place now if you talked
about the situation in indonesia the
survey
i would want to see how the i would yeah
you might i mean you might actually
allow a response to that because i think
that's a fairly
personal point um yeah i mean i i hope
we don't end up on a complete
totally off piece
on this but easy to the the charge seems
to be putting aside that big ideological
debate about the cia that you kind of
would say that wouldn't you because of
other elements of your belief system and
the institutions you've worked in
interesting oh well he forgot to mention
that
in 2018 i taught a course an intro to
blockchain course for morgan state
university in baltimore for actually was
the first course uh we believe the first
course to teach blockchain a formal
course at an uh what we call a hbcu
historically black college and
university um so you know if you if the
point is that i i don't think everyone
would say that i'm someone who uh always
it wants to obey authority but uh but
you know it's well taken i'm not here to
debate or be a spokesperson for the
central intelligence agency uh that was
a long time long time ago so that's not
the topic of the discussion but if you
want to know about me personally yeah i
could definitely i could you know you
know you know how i have lots of
actually um former folks that worked
under me not in government but who now
work in the crypto space um uh folks
that i sort of helped introduce crypto
to or at least learned a lot with them
um so i don't think it's a valid issue
to say because i work for the cia i
can't have valid analysis about some of
the risk uh if we take a sort of uh uh
uncautious approach to to crypto
so should we shall we consider that
aspect dealt with because i think we
could end up on this for for some time
but i think you would never talk you did
want to segue to another thought didn't
you well there is a there is a
relevant to this point because the focus
on uh there was a focus when i mentioned
uh kyc
and uh the illicit use of bitcoin or
credit that's know your customer isn't
it for those of us who don't live in
live in a world of uh acronyms about
this until we turned up tonight good but
the the
the problem with the kyc aml information
is that it doesn't stop the problem it
moves the problem so in forcing uh banks
to carry out a surveillance on behalf of
the government what they do is they make
banking a lot more expensive a lot more
difficult and it's an invasion of
privacy but it doesn't stop criminals
criminals just find other ways to move
money they don't turn around and say you
know what
i don't know how long of this money i'm
just gonna have to go in the real world
and get a proper job criminals just find
alternative ways to move money and move
value so it just moves the problem and
and it causes uh it moves the problem
moves the cost onto the banks and the
banks providing services to the
individuals
um but the illicit use of
cryptocurrencies is fundamentally a
false narrative uh i think it was
something like 2019 it was 2.3 percent
of all crypto
transactions were for illicit uses and
by 2020 that dropped point 2.34
we don't have the figures for 2021 but
my expectations is dropped a lot lower
so it is a forced narrative um and it's
uh these kind of ideas uh trick people
into thinking that bitcoin is used for
things like money laundering uh when i
was here at the protests uh in el
salvador and speaking to people against
bitcoin there are lots of people
perpetuating that uh myth that bitcoin
has used uh primarily for money
laundering so
um even so
even if some criminals get used
get the use of the bitcoin blockchain to
commit criminal acts i'm going to echo
what peter van valkenberg from the coin
center said for every one of those
people who uses bitcoin for illicit
purposes there is somebody who's using
it for freedom for economic freedom yeah
for every person who's using it to
launder money there's somebody
supporting protesters in
uh uh
protests against lukachenko's
dictator dictatorship who've decided to
strike and they've received donations
and they've had liquidity in their
country so they can survive and strike
so for every illicit use there is a
positive use and probably way more
because it's point three four percent so
in terms of um so i'm just going back to
um his um
main argument is that it doesn't solve
economic productivity again this is this
is just a false narrative because i've
seen i've seen it here in el salvador um
let's talk about remittance only firstly
i think it was today i think it was
western union claim they're going to
lose 400 million dollars of business to
uh bitcoin in el salvador that's 400
million dollars that can go now into the
pockets of people in the country rather
than the pockets of the people in uh
western union so that puts more money
into the economy here that can circulate
and if more money's in the uh in the
economy here circulating that's going to
lead to an increase in productivity and
the demand on services secondly by
having an appreciating asset as opposed
to a depreciating asset like the us
dollar remember no stimulus checks
reached the people of el salvador as the
u.s government continues to print more
money
janet yellen claiming
only this week that the debt ceiling
will be hit mid-october therefore there
will need to be release of more funds
trillions of dollars more to be printed
that's going to lead to inflation we're
seeing inflationary figures right now
anything depending who you talk to five
to ten percent that is making the cost
of goods more expensive for people in el
salvador so actually these people being
unbanked and and not and only having
access to the dollar are actually
seen uh seeing um a decrease in
productivity because they have to spend
more more money on importing goods now
by having just to conclude this point
then i think we should go back over to
yeah well so just to say that by having
access to something like bitcoin they
actually have access to some which is an
appreciating asset and what is this
false narrative that people
can't don't have the money to um to save
i asked the same question when i got
here one of the people i saw the protest
turned to me and says if i only have a
hundred dollars i have to spend that
hundred dollars on food i cannot afford
to i cannot afford bitcoin i went to
michael peterson a bitcoin b just
started the project here and he said i
had a similar belief when i got here but
what actually happened is when people
started holding bitcoin they realized
every purchase they make is a decision
if they buy that can of coke if they buy
that whatever that t-shirt that's
something that may be worth more money
in the future so people have
the ability to save even on very low
incomes have the ability to save even a
small amount and they can see that
appreciate in the future so i just
believe like eia's arguments are coming
from a false narrative
right yeah well i mean whether it's a
false narrative or one you just happen
to disagree with yeah you can pick up
the the points that you feel that you
want to nail before we go to q a which
is pretty busy actually q a yeah there's
an entirely parallel chat going on
in my chat box
it's a crypto discussion i'm sure i get
a lot of the feeling that this is like
this subject seems to attract people
it's either a mixture of a kind of hate
fest and a dating agency so i'm gonna do
is focus their passions run higher on
this than maybe i had realized so i'm
gonna concentrate on q a and take
questions from there and i'm to do that
in a but it's in in fairness i think you
should come back when i think you will
come back with and then we'll be yeah
i'll ju and i'll make it very quick uh
so i guess number one it was interesting
peter because you mentioned the i mean
you you basically said that um that the
in el salvador one of the good things
has been that people have been convinced
that uh they've been convinced to pay as
a use as a medium of exchange in
appreciating asset so that that that's
gonna make them say which is really kind
of odd because you basically said that
they're thinking about oh don't pay
don't pay for whatever groceries or some
item because your bitcoin could could uh
could could go up and and that doesn't
make it a good medium of exchange but
i'll leave that there um hit the other
two that's a completely separate point
that you've you've confused two points
i'm telling you no i'm saying that's a
point that you it's a fact it's
something that you said which was
interesting and i said well that's
actually not good this is what i'm
saying
you've misrepresented me
we could forget that point okay but
jury strike that from the record let's
go on to other which what the other
stuff you said elicit finance so i did
an actual report in 2018 co-authored
with tom robinson who works with
elliptic we actually did one of the
probably the first survey of illicit
finance and crypto yes we we we uh uh we
assessed that the percentage of illicit
crypto that you could identify was small
um we could talk about the numbers but
it was small but here's the real insight
that we found we found that in the u.s
and north america which had more aml
regulations and more regulatory guidance
in the crypto space compared to
everywhere else in the world especially
europe that there was a much smaller
percentage of illicit crypto in
transactions moving through north
american exchanges compared to exchanges
where there were no where you know where
you had no sort of aml regs lesson there
is that it's actually important yes of
course we know aml is not to stop money
laundering or to prevent crime from
happening it's to sort of raise the cost
and make it easier and some people would
say if it goes elsewhere it makes it
easier for law enforcement to identify
the bad actors the third point which is
about remittances and i sort of framed
this differently remittances is very
important i think we could argue and
maybe debate how well crypto has taken
off as a remittance substitute people
mention it all the time but i don't i
haven't really seen the the data that
says you know uh
people are all shifting to crypto
because it's much more easier and
efficient but here's one framing
i hate to say this but
hear me out remittances and improving
remittances while that's good if we can
make it more efficient i want you to
think of remittances as a first world
problem i know you're thinking what do
you mean it helps the third world yeah
improving remittances is a first world
problem why because what it does is yes
it's making it on the the back end in
terms of improving the ability for
people to send money where are they
sending they're sending from countries
that have stable economies much more
robust
more robust economy right what it's not
doing it is not directly changing the
economic productivity of the recipients
now yes it allows them to get more money
but you're not shifting you're not doing
anything for what poverty alleviation
needs which is the economic activity the
only thing you could say is well now
they have some extra money so maybe they
have extra money to do economic predict
predict uh productive things but you're
not changing the economic landscape per
se you're really it's really a problem
of of the sender who now maybe crypto
can help with that sending but doesn't
change doesn't help us do the economic
work that we have to do in countries
where we have large unbanked populations
i want to go over to q a i'm sure you
have uh thoughts to pick up on that
please but uh a q a seems to be so
probably tonight that they'll be bound
to find something in there that you can
get into if you have things that you'd
like to say along the way here's just uh
i want to kick us off it's anonymous i
fear but you tell us your names where
you can that's um very nice and we'll
send both participants around afterwards
to to give you a cup of tea um is
evading helping someone to sorry
is helping someone to evade kyc to get a
bitcoin wallet the same thing is banking
them it doesn't sound like the same
thing peter
hmm i need to think about the premise of
the question because uh it sounds like a
double like a here means the question is
it helping somebody
uh perform a little activity but helping
someone have a uh
uh crypto or bitcoin wallet to uh evade
the banking may be somebody who's living
in authority and regime who wants to
move money out of the country it could
be someone who has a female maybe within
uh the middle east within muslim
societies where perhaps they're not
allowed to so the premise of the
question is is strange i probably want
more detail on that to understand
exactly what they're asking but you know
kyc aml laws are
yeah eia supports them thinks they're
very important thinks they're very
useful i think they're oppressive and i
think they move the problem and i don't
think they particularly solve it at the
scale he thinks they do plus also you've
got a question what is illicit is it
illicit rules in the eyes of the
government the first time one of the
first times i've been it depends on the
government doesn't it
any power structure you happen to be
living in um
important to finish the point is that um
somebody would say buying cannabis oil
is an illicit activity something which
i've done but that was to buy a
treatment for my mother when she had
cancer so i think that some of this is
you know how do you frame what is a list
activity
did you want to come in on that one yet
sure this comes up a lot and i think the
way to think about it is that um you
know peter's right that crypto actually
has has shown a use in authoritarian
governments and in situations where um
lack of freedom makes it difficult for
people to purchase what they need to
purchase or to speak their minds etc um
the interesting point is that's the
problem the problem is that there's a
bigger issue here right that you're
basically what you're saying is that
crypto is helpful
in a situation that should not exist
that there's a problem with
authoritarian governments there's a
problem in a weakening economy where the
the currency is worth zero you know uh
you know falls to zero or whatever that
collapses right so you're basically
saying the use case is to help in these
situations which really should not be
exist where there's a bigger either
economic and political situation here's
the thing i say is someone born and
raised in the west and it's really sort
of shocking to me that so many of my you
know brothers and sisters from the us
and from europe it's almost as if we we
we
um
don't feel that other nations should
have what we have the key to actually
what we have is not that we have a
technology that keeps that allows us to
operate suit anonymously or anonymously
that's not the key to our freedom what's
the key to our freedom is that we have
accountability in our government
transparency we have principles that uh
that the government is built upon
accountability checks and balances it's
not all uh you know it's not all liberty
and it's not all
government surveillance this is why this
is not a simple issue there's not a
there's not an app for political and
economic liberty and freedom in fact
maybe that what you could say is at the
end of the day
maybe we should figure out how do we
help countries and nations become more
economically free or less restrictive do
you in the long term is a technological
solution going to do that because we see
what china is doing with the crypto
space
okay it's cracking down
a quick quick reminder if you're getting
as excited about this as uh our guests
and uh many of those attending you can
tweet using the hashtag uh
iq2crypto sorry hashtag iq2
crypto i am steadily adapting to the
21st century
how ive is asking banking and finance
have their own flaws and challenges have
they not is it believable that they will
adapt as regulators do not or as
regulators do not crack down with scare
propaganda and make transactions from
banks card companies etc more difficult
for crypto enthusiasts so yeah yeah i'll
start with you on that one yeah i think
because i sort of alluded to it so maybe
i'll take that and the point maybe i
didn't flesh out enough is that what i'm
seeing is someone who consults with the
crypto industry who yes has a national
security and anti-money laundering
background here's the thing that i'm
noticing i'm noticing that slowly but
surely a lot of the innovation that
we're seeing in the crypto space
banks are some banks are trying to to
regulate them there are even some you
know thought leaders in the traditional
payment space that are basically saying
that everything we have in banking
should should be on a blockchain and
should be uh you know we should figure
out how to apply smart contracts to our
financial services and this is even
though we love i mean everybody loves
this framing of david versus goliath
right it's the small crypto guy that's
trying to overturn the banks and yeah i
can criticize the banks because they
don't want to innovate but the key is
over time what i'm noticing i'm seeing
the steady march that those crypto
players that are trying to build sort of
unstable coins trying to build this new
ecosystem here's the thing that they
always come they always come up against
the wall where they realize they have to
adapt you just cannot have a scalable
financial market or financial system
that allows pseudonymity at scale and
the here's the here's the drawback and
i'll answer that sorry because i need to
get some questions and the last point is
that we always talk about the ease of of
virtue of the frictionless here's the
thing do you want an environment where
someone can send a hundred million a
billion dollars with no friction to
anyone that they can anonymously that
would unlock
i mean uh whole types of illicit
activity stuff that we don't even want
to talk about if if money was that
frictionless with no checks and balances
i'm sorry
peter
well we already have it you can send a
billion dollars
uh if if yeah i mean look uh achieving
that is going to be difficult at you
know that kind of scale uh but at the
moment you can send uh money
frictionless across the world instant
near zero fees uh
and have achieved final settlement which
is an amazing advancement in finance um
the walls have been built up by central
banks and the banking sector itself
they've just harmed people they've
harmed people in this country where i'm
in el salvador and they've harmed people
even in the uk where i am they make life
more difficult all for the chasing this
very tiny percentage of illicit activity
um
i don't
i i understand where you're coming from
you're coming from the fear index of
worrying about criminals and terrorists
etc etc i'm not i'm coming from the
opposite position of economic freedom
and are now in trade and allowing people
to move money around the world and not
being held back by the banking system
also come from the position of people
who see currencies devalue you know
we've seen what happened in venezuela
and zimbabwe we're seeing what's
happening in lebanon this year we've
seen what's happening in turkey we're
now seeing it happen in in the united
states people deserve access to our
money which isn't controlled by central
banks which isn't printed at a whim
which doesn't pay for the mistakes of
government and on top of that you have
permissionless censorship resistant
money you can send anywhere in the world
achieve final settlement yes there will
always be bad guys that's that's a fact
of life but if you can bring economic
freedom to the world what's the net
effect i think the net effect of that is
greater than what you lose by having the
ability to track every single criminal
in the world
thank you um that's admirably clear
we've got a number of questions in the
same sort of zone for for both of you so
i'll go back to yaya which is along the
lines of well this el salvador is a
relatively small scale example it has
particular social economic political um
context there uh someone says it's
actually this one's as a question to
peter but i think there's a balancing
one which says how much of that 400
million will actually end up in the
pockets of the poor uh all of bitcoin
atms and wallets hosted on amazon uh
being provided for free the sort of
balancing question somewhere high up in
the q a was along the the lines of well
if el salvador
failed if that experiment went south
would we have to accept that it was it's
an experiment that we take seriously and
there's a flaw uh in this unbanked
crypto unbanked argument because it had
failed would you simply say well that's
that just happened because of particular
circumstances and there was another
question along the same lines that said
where does cardano in ethiopia play into
this um i think we're going back to yaya
um
i think we have to be very careful
with the cavalier attitude of
experimenting with people's money again
i'm not trying to be the the cold the
cold water guy this el salvador i mean i
guess we have to talk about el salvador
and peter is on the ground peter i'll
give you my critique or my not christie
my concern
um again as someone who lives in a place
of representative government and
government accountability
it's troubling or it it's concerning
that even if it's an innovative way of
dealing with the currency crisis in the
money crisis it's concerning that
appears that this experiment has sort of
been pushed pushed through
without a really big consultive process
consultative process or strong buy-in
even from most of the business community
i think i saw the wall street journal
had a report where they talked about el
salvador's chamber of commerce that 90
some percent of the business or at least
the members of the chamber of commerce
did not um did not support this move to
to to bitcoin or yeah to bitcoin and i
think those of us again in in the west
how would we feel about you know one
politician getting inspired pushing
through something that would be so
radical and risky again not saying i
don't appreciate crypto i do i've taught
cr taught about the importance of crypto
and decentralized apps but the issue is
the consultative process um i think
that's really a big concern and and it
could go wrong not to be a fair guy but
come on would we stand for this in the
uk or in the united states
well you've moved into politics here and
these are the only questions that should
be asked if president buchalia and why
he made those decisions um the the the
political decision that he's taken has
uh almost zero to do with what bitcoin
itself can achieve so i think we should
separate the two i i i'll happily ask
those questions to be kaylee but they're
about his uh they're about his
administration the decisions they've
made that itself is a distraction from
the point of what bitcoin can do now if
you want to talk about bitcoin as an
experiment and it's an experiment that's
nearly 13 years old and we could talk
about fiat currencies they are also an
experiment but i think it's uh i think
it's hard to argue that uh bitcoin has
been a far greater success than fear the
fiat currencies fair currencies have led
to the collapse of countries they've
left to the decimations of people's
savings and they've also been used to
launder money around the world by
criminals
bitcoin itself has actually led to
people being asked to appreciate values
given economic freedom given economic
economic opportunity as a 13-year
project which came out of nowhere to me
it is an absolute roaring success
compared to the absolute failures by
central banks and just on the point of
cardano cardano is a [ __ ] coin and
what's been done in ethiopia there is
close to a scam i don't support it in
any way it's selling people a technology
they absolutely don't need
great okay that's not going in their
advertising campaign anytime soon is it
okay here we have um
a question which is a broad one and then
something that perhaps follows from it
i've decided it does you can tell me i'm
wrong is a financial system outside
sovereign control even possible i
suppose the reason i my mind went where
there was i i take
peter's points but obviously you simply
cannot compare the scale of what fiat
currencies and central banks are uh are
trying to do in the world as again
something which is is an emerging crypto
currency so i suppose the question would
be in the long run do you always
inevitably get back to sovereign or
state control uh it just may take a
longer
way uh you might have actually rather
different views on this yeah yeah
oh okay
the demi the um
how should i say it the uh the new the
the demise of the uh nation state has
been um widely uh exaggerated i know we
talk of we talk about this this world of
you know there should be no the nation
state is not necessary and it's called
done more harm than good
i think that's overstated i i say that
because you know my my point
um you know my point is that in my
study experience yeah i've come to this
conclusion
that you know if you do want to scale
and this is working with some of the
innovators in the industry right when i
advise them
i understand their desire to create a
freer more permissionless system of
transacting
i understand i think it's noble i think
there's there's room for it but i also
understand that you know again we're
talking about money money is different
than other technologies you know people
say well code is speech you can't
regulate the speed
but we're talking about value right you
can't have it both ways crypto folks you
can't say that this is value this is
digitizing value revolutionizing value
and then just say well it's speech and
you can't regulate it because it's just
code you can't have both ways because
the
the challenge is when you talked about
when you talk about value the world what
from different nations more
authoritarian to democratic all have
come to the conclusion that you have to
regulate
finance you have to regulate value
because they not yaya not the cia
not some bureaucrat people are
comfortable with the idea that they are
going to give the government power to
regulate up to a point finance we can't
escape it just because yeah now i can
create a token i create i can create a
protocol but you're to hit a ceiling i'm
sorry to say it's it's not like i'm
happy it's like i'm trying to you know
but that's that's the sort of rational
conclusion you come to when you try to
scale these protocols
it's a fair point
uh yeah and and i'm with you i'm not an
anarcho-capitalist i don't uh i don't in
the certainly in the short term see a
fall of the nation state uh but i do see
a world where bitcoin can bring more
accountability to the nation state and i
do see a world where the the state
becomes more of a service provider and
uh as they have restrictions placed on
the income they can derive uh from
uh from the the population now i i would
just say look
if you look at uh central bank's
policies they continually print and uh
debase currencies because you have a
group of guys in a room making decisions
that they're trying to balance an
economy let's look at a different way
bitcoin is entirely different this
monetary policy is essentially two rules
it's a fixed limit currency of 21
million coins which has an issuance rate
which halves every four years now what
happens is everybody understands those
rules everyone has to play by those
rules and adapt to it that to me is a
far fairer and better world than one
which is where the money is governed by
a few guys in a room making decisions
which are influenced by lobbyists and
their friends etc so yeah listen look
what world you want to live in do you
want to live in the world where let's
look at both extremes we have china on
one end cbdc's we're seeing the growth
of uh of authoritarianism across the
world so we have china with this social
credit score cbdc is where they can
control your money penalize you and take
your money for you if you don't follow
their strict guidance on how to behave
in their conformed society or do you
want to free a world where you have
access to financial services whoever you
are nobody can steal your money nobody
can take it from you and everybody has
the opportunity to save spend and send
that money where you want i know which
side which side i would go for
i'm going to actually stay with you then
clip back to yeah because i thought this
one would be a nice one if you guys see
sort of in the finish round of this and
then you get to do your
up some and we'll see how the voting is
looking money is important as is banking
what are the positive arguments for
moving them beyond democratic control
peter went back to you
i'm just trying to think i'm trying to
think what the question means
i think you can say that again
i'll do it again money is important i
think we can all agree on that what are
the positive arguments for moving money
and banking beyond democratic control so
i suppose it's flipping that way of
looking at
the sovereignty and the state of the
central bank standing behind currencies
fiat currencies and saying
uh if i mean if you don't if it's not a
question you think you can answer or
engage with you i think it's trying to
move on i just it intrigues me
i think that is trying to ask why would
you have a decentralized currency over
one which is i think i think that's what
it means isn't it yeah i mean yeah i've
gone for the mrs merton kind of
generalist view of this question
well i i just think i think the free
market for money will decide and i think
we're living in a a stage where we have
sovereign currencies and we have bitcoin
and you have a choice to hold your
wealth in whichever you choose i've
moved pretty much all of my money now
into bitcoin like 90
and i'm only using banks for
the ability to pay for certain things
like paying staff or paying for my
mortgage or car payments the things they
have to do through the traditional
banking system i've done that because i
get to control my money i get to manage
the security i get to manage my privacy
and i get to store my wealth in a way
that i want and that's to me is the kind
of world i want to live in and everyone
else can vote with their feet or vote
with their money you can choose to hold
your local sovereign currency or you can
choose to hold bitcoin the free market
will decide which money people want and
i've got a feeling bitcoin is going to
continue to grow as sovereign currencies
fail as we see seen in lebanon as we've
seen in turkey as we've seen in the
united states governments are trying to
print themselves out of their own errors
because government's got too big and i
think this is going to regulate
governments it's going to shrink the
size of government i think that's a
great thing
and yeah some thoughts from you there
and then we'll come to concluding
arguments
yeah just real quick i mean i think our
con that's a good question but i think
our conversation has veered off into
more an ideological discussion about you
know about crypto which is nice
bring it back home then yeah the
question is about yeah okay let's say a
bitcoin but the question is about can
bitcoin bank the unbanked and you know
what is the the value i mean what peter
i think what you just mentioned is that
you
the way i read what you said is that you
you have the luxuries to choose bitcoin
and i'm not against that i think people
should choose
whether it's bitcoin or sovereign
currency no one is no one is negating
that i'm trying to answer the question
about does the presence or or maybe the
push for let's say bitcoin is bitcoin
what the unbanked and the poorest of the
poor need because when you really talk
about the unbanked it's the poorest of
the poor and my my stance is that that's
not enough and that's probably that
shouldn't be the focus
right well we're coming to uh final vote
but you do get two minutes to uh to up
some i think what we do is uh do we
start voting i know we don't need to do
the summaries first in case there's a
breakthrough moment and a big swing in
those undecideds you get two minutes
each and i think this time we start with
yaya if there's anything that you feel
perhaps at the other side brought up
this might be a good time to to wrap
that in a couple of minutes
crypto can bank the unbanked go yaya
yeah maybe some things i should have
said at the top you know because you
know people hear cia they see they hear
those three letters and of course sounds
like they prejudge you sounds like they
think they know about you because you
worked for the central intelligence
agency
wow zimbabwe i've been in zimbabwe my
college thesis was a comparison of rural
development in zimbabwe and comparing
that with community development of youth
in inner city united states and i spent
six weeks in zimbabwe now this was i'm
older than i looked this was in the mid
90s
and i spent time in a local rural
village with no electricity and i saw
that the biggest thing that this one
organization was doing is it was helping
these youth who had left school um
generate income it was a youth it was a
carpentry group that was generating
income in rural cholocho uh in
matabelel zimbabwe and i'm not from
zimbabwe but i just remember that and
that was where i first sort of learned
that and then i spent i did a fulbright
in ghana uh after college uh on teachers
in rural rural incentives for teachers
in remote areas i spent a lot of time in
northern ghana um and so and and before
i joined the cia guess where i worked i
worked in inner city dc i was a math
teacher for three years this is all in
my record people people who know me know
this so i've sort of been connected to
you know community development the rural
development cetera i'll end with this
because i i know i gave a lot of facts
here is my anecdote my anecdote is i've
never gone viral i'm not a viral guy i
i'm not on social media a whole lot the
closest i've gone to viral was this
article i wrote uh at the beginning of
january called stop saying you want to
bank the unbanked shout out to forbes it
was it was in forbes and
that article i think is why i'm here
that article was recirculated mostly on
linkedin about three four months ago and
i kept getting all these um messages
from people in rural development
community development and microfinance i
know this is anecdotal but i just need
to just cut to the end of it as well the
ending is
most people said that
what i was saying reflected what they're
seeing on the ground that even though
they're doing micro finance and trying
to help people the unbanked they need to
generate income that's the number one
thing and it's not necessarily a
technological solution
okay thank you very much peter last
couple of minutes to you
and uh then stay with us guys because
we're gonna go for the vote
yeah i think i think one reflection the
premise of the debate is wrong because i
don't think yaya disagrees that
bitcoin can bank the unbanked but i
think it's hard to argue about against
the fact that people are able to access
banking services using apps being built
on the bitcoin network i think the
premise of the debate probably should
have been can uh bitcoin create uh
economic opportunity increase
productivity i think that would have
been a much better question we could
have debated it and and and i would
still have taken the side that yes it
can because really what we're discussing
is do you want an appreciating asset
versus a depreciating asset and
appreciating asset being held increases
the purchasing power of the individual
so that increases productivity within
the country because people have higher
spending power
also having the technology to receive
and send payments in places that haven't
had it before again increases
productivity i'll give one example this
week i visited in el salvador a facility
which helps
people with addictions get off the
streets okay
it's a small facility that survives on a
budget forty thousand dollars a year
i've reached out to the bitcoin
community and we've raised this same
facility to be around 140 000
in uh bitcoin that money now comes in
across the bitcoin network into this
country some of it gets spent as bitcoin
to bitcoin some gets converted to
dollars but that is increasing the
amount of money that's in the country
and that's increasing productivity only
this week they're out buying uh um the
products to improve the facility
actually they're moving to a new
facility uh they're buying beds they're
buying materials to improve the facility
so if you increase the flow of money
with an appreciating asset of course it
increases the productivity and economic
opportunity of the people there and the
thing is i've seen it i've been coming
here for two years this is my sixth time
here i've seen the changes to this small
town in el zante i've seen the
infrastructure that's been built i've
seen the people coming in so uh i think
the premise was wrong and i also think
on both points yaya would be wrong
right
now inconveniently for peter we're going
to vote on the premise that he thinks is
wrong but we didn't also talk about it
so uh crypto can bank the unbanked it's
time for i
she's okay i hear her maybe it's your
audio peter can you hear me uh okay
thank you thank you very much for that
heads up but no i think i'm afraid i
think it's you might be your audio peter
here we go
uh cryptogram banked here is a poll
appearing on your screen and i think by
the quality of the questions you're very
bright and can tell that poor against an
undecided means for against or undecided
i'm sorry peter if you've lost
sound i i fear if you can hear me it may
be at your end let's hope we get you
you back
um so we'll get your voting please for
against
undecided on the motion while we're
waiting for that to come in i'd like to
remind you this is the third debate in
the intelligence squared crypto series
if you've enjoyed it we hope you have
you can catch up on the first two they
were bitcoin versus gold with anthony
scaramucci and peter schiff equally as
passionate as the debate you've heard
tonight and crypto versus the
environment with lynn olden and alex
davis on the intelligent square podcast
and youtube channel
but now it is time i hope to reveal the
results
and
the first vote to remind ourselves was
49 percent against
15 undecided sorry absolutely utter
rubbish i'll start again first was 49 4
15 against undecided 36 the second vote
is for
59
against 27
and undecided 14
so that was a big big swing there from
the undecideds to for the motion for the
motion carries it 59
27 against and immediately 14
undecided after that fire fight uh thank
you very much for doing battle for us
tonight